e
Bédard, l'a rencontré.e e e e es
grandes places du Kazakhstan, la
colère, elle, est toujours aussi
vive pour cet opposant politique
MOUKHTAR ABLIAZOV,
sasasant kazakh
- Pour être honnête, je ne
croyais pas que popopopopopopops
de masse, et je l'ai même dit
Je n'y croyais pas. Et j'ai même
exprimé ma position partout
réaliste parce que s'ils
le font, ils sont fous.
- Moukhtar Abliazov a été
au Kazakhstan avant de fuir
son pays. Il a fonpapapaparti
d'opposition, mobilisé surtout
depuis l'étranger. Aujourd'hui,h
de sous-estimer grossièrement
le nombre de morts tombés
sous les balles des forces
(coups de feu)
- Nousnsnsnsns qu'il y a en fait
plus d'un millier de victimes,
et les autorités disen d d d d ,
ce qui signifie qu'elles sous-
à plusieurs reprises.
Nous cnsnsnsnsns qu'il s'agit
simplement d'un massacre.
- Il en veut pour preuve les
dizaines de vidéos qui circulent
sur les réseaux sociaux et qui
lu
On y voit des sacs mortuaires
qui défilent, innomb
dans les morgues de deux
hôpitaux d'Almaty,
(cris de protestation)
La ville a étdedededededededed,
qui se sont révolté, parfois
violement, contre la hausse
des prix de l'essence.
bien au-delà et qui n'a pas dit
son dernier mot.
- Les gens ont compris ce queust
que grâce à l'intervention
de Poutinea changé. Nous n'attes
que l'aide internationale
pour amener Poutine à quitter
le Kazakhstan. Ensuite,cecececee
va commencer.KaKaKaKaKaKaKaKaKa,
Kassym-Jomart Tokaïev, affirme
que son pays a déjoué
une tentative de coup d'État,
la preuve en apporter la preuve.
ononononononférence avec le
président russe, qui a dépêché
2000 soldats pounenenenenenenené
que les évènements sanglants
la semaine dernière avaient été
orchestrés depuis l'étranger.
"Nous n p p p p p p personne
déstabiliser la situation
chez nous et mettre en oeu r r s
colorés", a dit aujourd'hui
Vladimir Poutine, en référence
aux différentes révolutions
au début des années 2000.
- Poutine veut construire un
prototype de l'Union soviétique
et conquérir progressivement
pour manipuler, comme dans
le cas du Kaeueueueueueueueut
prendre le contrôle de toute
l'Asie centrale et construir a .
Il veut des troupes et que
tout soit sous son contrôle.
Mais cela n'arrivera pas.
et ce sera une résistance
ririririririririeuse. Et beaucop
de personnes se prononceront
en disant que atatatatatatatata.
- Il appelle la communauté
internationale à imposer
des sanctions sévères
pour prévenir de nouveaux bains
de sang. Lt
à devenir premier ministre
d'un gouvernement provis i i i t
pas retourner au Kazakhstan.
En 2017, cet ancien oligarque
a été condamné en son absence
affaire de détournement de fonde
BTA. En lui accordant l'asile,
la justice s s s s s s s s s s s
dont le mobile est
purement politique.
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard,
Radio-Canada,